тися От бачите чому сьогодні немає суду
тому що два дня чи три дня тому суддя
подала у відставку Напевно що стидно
судити військових Ну напевно що їй Може
вона має десь родичів які служать Може
ще щось І Напевно вона прийняла таке
рішення що вона не буде Приймати участь
от в тому цирку який влаштовує офіс
президент
опзж має бути закрита як політична сила
е-е ці люди які представляють її в
парламенті мають скласти мандати до чого
зараз помаленьку це все якраз і доходить
і ми говорили що в тому числі і Волошин
є зрадником після повномасштабного
вторнення ми це все побачили людина ее
втікла відповідно до своїх господарів ее
в московію і зараз там